hey guys how's it going we are back with
another iPhone 7 video there hasn't
really been that much news but with WWDC
right around the corner it's probably a
good time to maybe chat about it
although I don't think that they're
gonna be announcing much at WWC with the
iPhone 7 usually WDC is focused mostly
on sort of the software aspect of
Apple's lineup but you never know they
do tend to surprise us so what can we
expect at WWDC 2016 one of the things
that I was really really hoping for that
Apple is not gonna be unveiling external
displays at WWDC at this point it's I've
given up these have not been updated in
so long that it is kind of depressing
and by now there's so many displays that
are so much better than what they've
already currently got out there I
actually have another display on the way
I know we had this discussion when I
first upgraded to the Mac Pro trashcan
tower which also has it really been
updated since 2013 so there's that so no
new display no new hardware but plenty
of Siri updates oh and maybe some
iMessage updates and some Apple pay
updates those don't really sound that
exciting what will be exciting though
about Siri is they're going to be
opening it up to third-party apps so
Siri is gonna be a larger part of the
keynote user control music text calls
email so the reason it's taking so long
as privacy concerns will apps have to be
approved to be a part of SDK which I
think that's actually a good idea and
that's one of the best things I think
about Apple is sort of their app
approval process because I feel like a
lot of things that are in sort of the
Google Play Store and the Android Market
it doesn't have that extensive hogan
approval process so there's a lot of
crap out there Mac books will get touch
ID in an OLED screen above the keyboard
okay but how about a touch screen it
blows my mind the Apple has not made a
touchscreen display yet I mean I realize
that you want us to buy iPads or the
touch screen will just be real for a
second Apple plans have introduced
dramatically overhauled macbook pro
later this year the device will have a
newer thinner lighter design ereport
from earlier this month claimed that
Apple was looking into providing a way
to unlock Macs via touch ID on an iPhone
but now appears the company is also
looking into adding physical hardware to
Mac books as well I think
that's kind of a really cool thing
because I do love having touch ID on my
phone so having that on my MacBook will
be pretty cool still upset about no new
displays but it's cool I'm over it some
of the things to expect possibly from
WWC iOS design refresh big enhancement
to photos Apple music app can you just
raise your hand if you guys what we
actually can't raise your hand so just
leave a comment if you guys actually do
use the Apple music app because I do not
I like that they're trying to be more
spotify ish not sure of changing the
color scheme is gonna be what makes us
use it more it's also strange because
sometimes I want to purchase a song and
the process to buy the song I feel like
takes several extra steps so it's clear
that they're trying to obviously push
streaming a lot more but what if I
actually want to buy the song iMessage
to get financial transfers via Apple pay
that would be pretty cool to be able to
pay people through iMessage coach Apple
watch bands
this band yes but those little extra
little bangles I'm gonna go with some
nope those are one of those things you
need to actually see in person so it
looks like they'll definitely be
announcing some new watch bands with
some new retailers so that's kind of
cool whoa look at this this white one
looks really good while Beast camo love
this is exciting
I love my Apple watch I'm hoping that
they will announce some cool things for
the Apple watch this was supposed to be
a video about the iPhone 7 but we have
completely gotten off topic
iPhone 7 iPhone 7 plus cases a surface
show of smart connector and dual camera
design so these are all things that we
have discussed previously in videos but
it looks like as we're nearing closer to
the time of a possible announcement new
case designs are coming out but here's
the thing if I had a 3d printer I could
print out an iPhone case and I can make
it look however I want and start posting
things online saying oh my goodness this
is a prototype but also a lot of these
companies are making prototypes for
potential things that they think that
the iPhone is going to be no one really
knows I mean some people know it's
unclear what the purpose of the smart
connector would facilitate an iPad pro
Apple uses smart connector to enable
sleek keyboard cases and accessories
that doesn't seem like a six inch
keyboard cover would be useful I love
the smart
battery case that they have for the
smaller sixes hopefully this means that
they can potentially make one for the
six plus or the seven plus this is also
some big news that people were
mentioning and it's something that I
think is kind of important that they're
finally dropping the 16 gigabyte models
I've had so many issues even upgrading
software and I have 128 gig version I
fill this thing up so quickly with
pictures and video and apps and
everything of course I don't think I'm
like your normal average iPhone user but
even my mom when we were using her phone
before and trying to upgrade to the
latest OS we had a lot of struggles and
she had the 16 gig model the analyst
also claimed the iPhone 7 will feature
two gigs of RAM my card two gigs of ram
I'm thinking back to the days of when
like 32 megabytes of RAM was like a huge
upgrade on a computer
customers increasingly find that 16 gig
phone is not suitable for their needs
just which is true if you're recording
in 4k and making all kinds of videos of
your kids or your friends or your family
or your dog which is what I'm mostly
doing then you're gonna fill up that
phone really quick which looks like the
iPhone 7 could actually go up to 256
gigs of storage that would be great
there will be no OLED displays in this
year's iPhone Apple instead making a
switch in 2017 or 2018 which is another
reason that they're also saying just
wait until next year this is a great
header lightning headphones are they
better or just in inconvenience well in
their tests it has sounded better so
there's our answer but not really that
picky when it comes to headphones I
mostly want something small portable
easy to carry with me hopefully I won't
lose them I don't really the huge
problem with them are moving the
headphone jack it just sucks because I
have so many pairs of headphones so
using an adapter is gonna be annoying
because I'll probably lose the adapter
addition to losing my headphones so the
struggle probably will be real for a
while it definitely is a new technology
so clearly they are going to be able to
do so much more with it it's just gonna
be annoying it's gonna be an
inconvenience for a while so really when
it comes down to it I've made several
other videos about the iPhone 7 and
there hasn't been much news lately the
biggest news though is WWDC that will be
coming up next week so I'm sure it will
make another
do after her that all happens and we can
chat about all the things that were
announced and released so until then you
guys can chat in the comments and I will
chat with you and we can talk about what
to expect what we're looking forward to
for the iPhone 7 and if there are any
other new rumors anyway
I'm excited I think mostly I'm gonna be
super pumped to try out the dual camera
function I always love trying to find
new ways to vlog and new things to try
so that'd be kind of cool to see what we
can do with that but until then no one
really knows what's gonna happen so I'll
see you guys in the next video bye